l'image elle est là elle est parfaite et
ben en fait j'ai fait aligné à gauche et
ben du coup en fait ça déformé le texte
en fait démystifier un univers parfois
obscur c'est l'objectif du sprint camp
organisé au campus numérique à hencour
le concept s'initier à C professions du
digital gratuitement durant 10 jours la
trentaine de participants cinquantinois
a pu découvrir les métiers de
développeur cybercurité community
manager ou web designer pour ces
personnes parfois élogées du monde du
travail pas de prérequis seulement la
motivation d'apprendre c'est vraiment la
première étape
vers retourner en formation après enfin
ou retourner à l'emploi mais c'est juste
remettre le pied à
l'étrier développer des nouveau des
nouvelles compétences se sentir en
confiance avec les compétences qu'on
possède on le voit il y en a pour
certains qui savaient tout juste allumer
un ordinateur et qui et qui ressortent
de laedans avec au moins des cordes en
plus et et des envies supplémentaires de
se dire aussi qu'on peut tout simplement
y arriver après une formation de
graphiste café China 28 ans a décidé
d'intégrer le sprint camp pour acquérir
de nouvelles connaissances numériques en
3 jours elle a créé sa propre page
internet sur Wix avec l'aide de sa
formatrice Sandra je me lance en
freelance bon pour faire des chates
graphiques vraiment me spécialiser dans
la chat graphique et tout donc
éventuellement aussi faire des sites web
pourou des gens habituellement qu' qu'it
pas quelque chose et que on est en face
d'une grande personne qu'on est
de quelqu'un quand on est déjà adulte on
a du mal à poser des questions mais
c'était vraiment comme des discussions
et ça passait crème ils ont une manière
en fait de t'apprendre sont te rendre
stupide animation en Javascript ou
création graphique sur l'application
canva le dernier jour de formation s'est
conclu le 29 septembre par une
présentation des différents projets
entre les apprenants une occasion de
gagner en confiance grâce à de nouvelles
compétences personnelles pourquoi je